We are living in a special century. The
first in Earth's history when one
species is empowered to control the fate
of the entire biosphere. To jumpstart a
transition to entities that far
transcend our limitations. Or, to take a
darker view, to foreclose the immense
future potential and leave an anarchic
and depleted planet. So how can we
forestall catastrophes and ensure a
brighter future? We need to think
globally.
We need to think rationally—empowered by 21st century technology but guided by
values that science itself can't provide. And above all, we need to think long-term.
A secular organization, The Long Now
Foundation, will create a symbol to contrast
dramatically with our currently pervasive short-termism. In a cavern deep
underground, a massive clock will be
built, designed to tick for 10,000 years,
to resound with a different chime every day over that expanse of time. Those of us
who visit it this century will
contemplate a monument built to outlast
the cathedrals and will be inspired to
hope that 100 centuries from now it will
indeed still be ticking and that some of
our progeny will still be there to visit
it. And I give the very last word to
one of my scientific heroes, the eloquent
biologist Peter Medawar. I quote:
"The bells that toll for mankind are like the
bells of Alpine cattle. They're attached
to our own necks, and it must be our fault
if they don't make a cheerful and melodious sound." Thank you very much for listening.